Sky Londres 2002 c'est une photographie
de Thierry fontaine un artiste
réunionnais qui vit et travaille à la
Réunion et Paris en même temps il a
explosé dans le monde entier
il a été pensionnaire à la Villa Médicis
en 1999 et il a réalisé cette
photographie lors d'une résidence
d'artistes en Angleterre
c'est une oeuvre magnifique d'une grande
simplicité qui concentre pourtant en
elle une dimension à la fois cosmique
dans cette allusion au ciel étoilée et
une dimension plus spirituelle par cette
compassion pour la condition humaine sur
Terre c'est un effet un manteau que les
personnes
en situation précaire pose au sol et
attendent ensuite l'aumône et
Thierry Fontaine a réalisé un coup de
génie je trouve parce que c'est un cette
grande économie de moyens il a
simplement inversé le sens de la
photographie c'est en effet une
photographie faite en vue plongeante
et le simple fait de l'avoir inversé
donne l'impression d'une vue d'en
contre-plongée et donne l'impression
d'un ciel d'où son titre Sky c'est
une œuvre dans laquelle le ciel et la
terre se rejoignent d'une certaine
manière
par justement cette grande simplicité de
moyens
grand économie de moyens et on peut
aussi noter la qualité formelle cette
photographie avec ce bleu qui est
lumineux qui exprime l'émotion de
l'artiste et cette lumière céleste par
le scintillement des ors représentés par
des petites pièces se poser sur le
manteau au sol voilà c'est une oeuvre
fait partie des collections de
l'artothèque Thierry fontaine est
représenté
par ailleurs par d'autres œuvres qui est
également
proposé aux abonnés inscrits auprès de